KATY PRUDIC: Butterflies
are amazing creatures.
Of course, we admire them for
their beauty and their grace.
They have many important
roles in an environment.
They are eating plants.
They're pollinating plants.
They're also being eaten
by birds, lizards, mammals.
Everybody wants to eat
a tasty caterpillar.
So butterflies are
central to a lot
of the interactions that are
happening within a community.
Is that a monarch?
HANK VERBAIS: Yeah, yeah yeah.
KATY PRUDIC: And incoming.
HANK VERBAIS: Yeah,
it's pretty fresh.
KATY PRUDIC: Yeah,
aren't you beautiful?
HANK VERBAIS:
Yeah, look at that.
That's beautiful.
KATY PRUDIC: You're
a gorgeous girl.
HANK VERBAIS: OK, so we're
going to take the tag.
KATY PRUDIC: And you can
tell it's girl why, Hanky?
HANK VERBAIS: There
is no scent gland,
if that's the
correct name, yeah.
I wanted you to see it.
OK, good, AZ 530.
So cool.
Good job.
I'm here today to learn more
about Adventure Scientists
and how to collect
data on butterflies
and flowering plants for
Adventure Scientists projects
that are going on.
MICHELLE TOSHACK:
Adventures Scientists
is a nonprofit based
out of Bozeman, Montana.
We do the volunteer management.
And then we partner
with researchers
who have specific
conservation concerns where
data is a limiting factor.
And so we have this
network of volunteers,
not only over the US
but through the world.
Some of our projects
are global projects.
KATY PRUDIC: So the
proboscis is out, right?
So he's probing with his
proboscis, which is his straw.
Butterflies are great indicators
of how an ecosystem is doing.
I think it signifies whether
this habitat is working,
whether it's able to
support a variety of life,
whether you'll have a lot of
birds there, a lot of mammals.
A lot of interactions
are happening.
So a diverse place is often
a very productive place.